the masterpiece that is Birdemic shock
and terror was released this week on DVD
and blu-ray and lived up to every one of
my expectations hi I'm Alan Bock and I'm
the star of Birdemic the fifth worst
film rated by IMDB I think my luck has
changed since I met you last week the
company NCT software that I work for was
bought for a billion dollars by Oracle
Corporation and this week my startup
company that I founded
mass solar got funded ten million
dollars by evergreen capital I think the
moment that I wanted to be an actor was
I was going to college I was studying
architecture but then I just didn't like
it anymore so I was like you know what
I'm gonna do something that I really
love to do and so I decided to go into
acting I actually had an online acting
profile through now casting comm one day
the director James Doohan called me and
he said that he wanted to cast me for
his film for Demick Birdemic shock and
terror supposed to be a very serious
romantic thriller yes he asked me to
come down to San Jose which was a
two-hour drive from Sacramento but I
didn't care you know was my first film
so I decided to meet him I was really
excited I did without an agent I met
with him at a high school and he asked
me to do a monologue and the only
monologue that I knew back then was a
scene from the boiler room act as if you
understand what that means act as if you
are the president of this firm so I did
that maybe for like 10 seconds and the
him he said great he said you got the
part at first it was like a full cast
and crew type of deal so it was pretty
good and then three weeks into it the
crew I don't know what happened with
them but then they got eliminated so
working on set on Birdemic was you know
very challenging I made a lot of
sacrifices Monday through Friday I was
going to school I was work
as well and then on the weekends I would
drive from Sacramento to the other
actors house and then to San Jose or
Half Moon Bay work 12 hours I almost
fell asleep a few times on the road one
night James aside enough to go back so I
actually had to spend the night at a
7-eleven parking lot I remember
production wrapped probably around seven
months you know when we wrapped it was
definitely a relief I remember one day I
went to James's house and he showed me a
rough cut I saw the film and I was like
okay maybe he'll fix the birds because
that's what he said he was working on
and then after that I didn't hear
anything from him and then he told me he
put it on YouTube and it went viral this
movie right here Birdemic shock and tear
f is nothing they could prepare you for
this
I remember it being shown on the soup
those birds are cook of World War two
fighter planes sound effects go huh god
help us off it was featured on the New
York Times I mean when it first got
released and went viral I didn't even
come out like that yeah it was it was a
little bit I wouldn't say embarrassing
but like you know every actor wants to
first film to be you know great and for
a low-budget film you know he did his
best so yeah
did I ever think that you know maybe
this was not the right move I would say
no because I was just really excited
that I was cast my first film and I just
wanted to start a project and finish it
but you know you've knows very
low-budget it wasn't like the best film
it actually had a niche for certain fans
so it got its really popular people are
reaching out to me and they really loved
it so I was like you know I'll just
embrace it
[Music]
[Applause]
after Birdemic won a producer reached
out to me I was like hey James just rope
or Demi - and we want to cast you as a
lead of course and then we shot Birdemic
- it was a little bit much more smoother
production because you know we a little
bit bigger budget I had a crew I also
got to go on the Birdemic tour they took
me to 20-plus cities all over the US and
then London in Paris so I got to go to
midnight showings and meet my fans face
to face so I thought that was pretty
awesome acting is really hard is
challenging there's definitely a
struggle towards it trying to achieve
that high goal of you know making it and
in Hollywood epidemic it did give me a
boost in my acting career but then you
know you have your highs and lows and
went from high with Birdemic
and then it went low and I'm uh saying
that I didn't feel like I wanted to give
up there were times when I did feel like
it but you know you just have to have
faith
the Birdemic franchise does have a lot
of fans and you know they reach out to
me all the time and they're really nice
and positive and they really love the
films they love me acting in the film
it's just a great feeling when you get
the fans reaching out Tunes sing you
know that they really enjoy the film
that you're in some of the hopes I have
for acting is of course continued acting
in films
my motto is that I I'm not going to give
up I'm gonna keep trying and trying
until I get it and eventually I'll get
it from 35 40 60 eventually I'll get
[Music]